joining us now with reaction foxnews
national security strategist former
deputy assistant to the president
Sebastian Gorka Salem radio nationally
syndicated host Larry elder both of you
are laughing I think Larry is laughing
harder so go to him first Larry well
Sean if you know anything about this
town you know that they're gonna embrace
James call me like nobody's business
in fact I'm surprised they haven't
talked about an action figure or reality
show something like at homee with the
commis it's come with me he's gonna be
embraced yeah James Colleen yeah having
Riggins I don't read an investigation by
James Comey that's another good one you
remember the movie hurricane that
celebrated the life of a man who
murdered three people no question that
he murdered three people let's not
forget the movie that was done with Dan
Robert rather called truth which
celebrated with done with Robert Redford
rather playing dan Rather called truth
which celebrated the lie that rather
push arguing that george w bush got
preferred treatment with the Texas Air
National Guard and don't forget the
movie that celebrate the life of Joe
Wilson and Valerie Plame even though the
Washington Post in an editorial even
said Joe Wilson lied about president
george w bush and the words that he used
at the State of the Union speech so
believe me this town is going to embrace
them some Jim Comey the only question is
how much more are they gonna embrace
Robert Mullen when he writes his book
you know dr. korkor we know he released
privileged information so he could get a
special counsel turns out to be his best
friend we also know that he rigged the
investigation into Hillary that's that
evidence is so overwhelming I can't wait
for the IG report and we also know that
he was aware Hillary paid for the but
the phony Russian dossier they presented
it before a FISA Court and they didn't
tell the FISA Court some key bits of
information like Oh Hillary paid for
this it's a political document and not
only is it not verified it's full of
lies but they got the FISA warrant four
times that way sure Larry is absolutely
right the cesspit the cesspool that his
Hollywood will embrace this man
absolutely because he's a navel-gazing
egotist who has no moral compass just
like Hollywood
you know you have to laugh because you'd
think that sooner or later they get the
message nobody's going to watch their
films when you watch the Oscars they
insult most of America and and you know
they could turn it around they could
just turn it around they could say okay
we're gonna do a movie about how bent
cops got an illegal warrant to spy on
American citizen during a presidential
campaign we're gonna do a documentary
style drama piece about a woman who ran
for president and then illegally put a
hundred and eight top secret emails on
her see can't make it up
no people would go and see those movies
people would start it's that good
Hollywood let me play both you I don't
have a lot of time let me play this is
crazy Uncle Joe Biden giving a speech in
Miami Tuesday when a guy who ended up
becoming our national leader said I can
grab a woman anywhere and she likes it
and then said I made a mistake a mistake
but they asked me would I like to debate
this gentleman and I said no I said if
we were in high school I'd take you
behind the gym and beat the hell out of
them Oh
big tough on crazy Uncle Joe imagine and
I never would say this and I trained
pretty hard MMA five days a week what if
I did say which I'd never say crazy
Uncle Joe come meet me in the Octagon
what would the reaction be Larry elder
well you know what the reaction would be
and Shawn there was a book called no one
left a lie - written by Christopher
Hitchens lefty Houston right for Nation
magazine he said that there were three
plausible allegations of rape against
Bill Clinton nobody cared about this
book there's another book called
confidence man written by Ron Suskind
who's a Pulitzer Prize winner came out
during the Obama administration and said
that because of the sexism in the Obama
White House if this were the private
sector we could bring it up - let me
tell you on the hostile workplace
violations nobody cared this book comes
out all my goodness let's do a movie
last word dr. korkor Joe Biden crazy
Uncle Joe yeah the man who got every
issue wrong for 30 years that's what I
want to say about lunch bucket jokes by
the way you can't work at a 7-eleven
unless you have a slight Indian
said he's bright he's articulate all
days talking about Obama remember those
words all right guys